all right uh welcome back everybody to
the last uh last talk of this afternoon
session
uh it's a pleasure to have chile from uh
who's a researcher at the princeton
university
uh chief take it
away okay
um thank you for the introduction so
today i'm very happy to be able to talk
to you about some of my recent thoughts
on domain adaptation or handling
distribution shift in general with label
propagation
and this is a joint work with my
wonderful collaborators
and this talk is based on two of these
papers
okay
nowadays with the tremendous development
of machine learning people are eager to
apply the technology to real-world
scenarios like autonomous driving health
care and the robotics
however in real deployment people often
often see failure cases that prevent us
from expanding their usage
because people won't trust our models
with those failure evidence
so what is the problem why do our model
fail in real life even though i'm sure
they have been tested extensively in
simulation and other testing scenarios
one problem is that to learn the machine
learning models tend to be non-robust
not only to uh not robust to adversarial
attacks which is one of the theme of
this workshop but also to distributional
shift
and this is the focus of this talk
and another problem is that they can be
on principled this means they are not in
enough theoretical analysis to support
much of the existing work on handling
distributional shift and we would need
more theory to help us understand the
working scenarios of existing work and
guide us towards better algorithm
designs
so in this talk i will first introduce
different kinds of distributional shift
and discuss a little bit of the prior
work
and
i will introduce a new method um it is
not entirely new but there are certain
like
innovations and uh differences in the
proposed algorithm and i will propose
some theoretical analysis of that
followed by some empirical validation
and one important part of this new
algorithm is that it is designed on the
representation space has satisfied some
certain good properties and i will talk
about that in the end
so first let me introduce different
types of distribution shift
so in general distribution shift means
like when we have the input signal x and
the label y
the the joint distribution has changed
from the source domain where we train
our model to the target domain where we
test our
and there are different types of corrupt
of distributional shift for example
cover shift means that the marginal
distribution
are different in the source and target
domain
while the relationship between y and x
or y given x remains unchanged
this is still very challenging even
though the difference only comes from
the marginal distribution for example
here you can see that in the source
domain we have like
the labels or the data from the two
classes
well
a simple linear classifier might be able
to distinguish them
but when you try to extrapolate it to
other regions you have missing it is
very possible that
since you haven't seen the other regions
your previous predictor is entirely
wrong
and there are other types of
distribution shift like motor shift even
the
even the conditional distribution of y
given x has changed or labeled shift
which means the probability of y are
different
our focus will be on covalent shift
and cover shift is ubiquitous phenomenon
for instance in this brief data set you
can say
you can see that with the source domain
even though there are birds
it's possible in the system they have
more like green land background or water
background but in the target domain they
have like
a sky background
so they have different marginal
distribution
however better this image is a bird or a
table well or some other labels is
associated with the image semantic
meanings for another environment
therefore in this example some believe
we only need to tackle the issue of
shift well the
relationship between the label and the
image has not changed
and the target specific in this talk is
to design the some principled way to
handle covalent shift with some
additional information because without
any additional information there's no
way we can
handle coercer shift and we assume that
we have additional unlabeled samples
from the target domain
so since i mentioned that this
phenomenon this phenomenon is ubiquitous
there have been extensive studies on
handling career shift
the list is very inexhaustive
but i just want to discuss a little bit
uh
one
of the most traditional mesh methods
should be like important sampling
so instead of like a
minimize or like the empirical risk
minimization on the unweighted
summation of
the loss function on each samples pure
importance simply will just rebate each
sample with the density ratio
from the target domain and the sustain
and the
the motivation is very straightforward
it it wants to like reduce the selection
bias
of all the samples
but there are a lot of caveats here
because first it will require that the
support of the target domain to be
contained in support of the source
domain otherwise
this value can explode to infinity
if there is certain sample that we only
see from the target domain but never
seen from the source domain
and it's also hard to estimate the
density ratio but the problem itself i
i'm not sure if it's even like simpler
than the original problem itself
um and the third
this procedure might reduce the bias but
might also inflate the variance
especially if this value is very large
at some points
and another type of algorithm
is distributional matching
and it is down through a lot of like
domain adversarial algorithms
and there are other types of algorithms
that ensure that we learn some invariant
representation
by environment it means that the
representation performs similarly across
different domains
however
there are there are actually a lot of
analysis on this kind of algorithm
that like forcing the representation to
match might not preserve the right
information for my given x
so today in this talk i will propose the
label propagation idea so this idea is
not entirely new but there were not like
enough theoretical support and today i
will go i'm going to discuss like why
and when it will work
and watching changes we have done to
make it work better
so is there any questions for now
okay then i will move on to the
our framework on label propagation
so as we mentioned that we have the
source and target domain and
to indicate the algorithm let's just
look at this illustrating example
on the source domain we have the data
from two classes the blue ones uh class
minus one the right the red ones the
right boss are class one
and
suppose we have a teacher classified
that performs reasonably well on those
samples
that it can distinguish between
red and blue quite well but as we
mentioned that when
it applies to the target domain it can
be like entirely wrong on some part of
the data
and the main idea of labor propagation
is to notice that this teacher classify
violates a certain important rule
which is that the data with
that are close to each other with
similar semantic meanings should predict
the same or predicts that is similar
however in this region let's call that
inconsistent set
these are the data points that are there
exists some data point close to it but
your classifier just predicted entirely
different
therefore the main idea of label
propagation is to reduce the possibility
of this kind of inconsistent set
and what it does is the first to
minimize the difference between your
learned classified with the teacher
classified on the source domain
because the source domain is where you
trust the result you trust the
prediction
and in the meantime ensure the samples
with similar semantic meanings to
predict similarly
in that way on each like these
components
or the idea is like you realize that on
the source domain the majority
of the predictor is one
and you also want the predictions to be
consistent so you are trying to
propagate the crack label one to the
entire domain
to the entire component
so that is the idea of label propagation
but here notice i said that we want to
ensure the samples with similar semantic
meanings to predict similarly but of
course here i'm like using
l2 distance to measure the semantic
similarity that doesn't really make
sense
so
actually
we should capture the semantic
similarity in a different space
and we should build the data in a good
representation space where their
distance is something we trust
that can
capture their semantic similarities so i
will discuss how to obtain this kind of
representation space with
self-supervised learning in the end
but now suppose we already have such a
good space
and let me just introduce its properties
because i don't want to distract you too
much from the main story of label
propagation for now
so let's say we here we have a good
representation
space it just means that we map the data
from the input
pixel values to a
vector space that can like represent
the data similarities with those space
distance
then with this representation space we
can actually divide the data
into different subgroups so again here
we have two classes the blue ones and
the red ones
and
with determination
and the distance in the representation
space those data are naturally splitted
into subgroups
so what do i mean
for example
we have like uh suppose the
the blue tests are like the class of
first
and uh here we have uh
different
types of different kinds of birds they
are from different environments
like this one has like a water
background and this one has bring back
the greenland background
and
they might not be directly conducted by
determination meaning there is not a
determination that maps this image to
this image but they can still be like
considered connected in these components
because
there might exist some data mutation
like random crop that
crop the head part of this image and the
head part of this image and they are
close to each other in the
representation space
therefore i'm saying like these
components are the data points
that are
directly or indirectly connected to each
other with
label with data annotation or they are
close to each other in this
representation space
and
the number of those components highly
depend on the strengths of of the data
mutation suppose you have very weak
determination where you only generate
one
different image for each sample then
there will be like millions of
components but if you have quite
stronger
data mutation then this will be like a
large components
like these are components of like the
black and white wobbler and
this part might be a component of eagle
uh is this part clear
thank you
okay
and if
we are able to like split the data into
the subgroups we can actually uh
propagate the data from like
the crack labels we have with the
teacher network
to
the other region in each component
and here i will try to present more
formally the algorithm of label
propagation
let's say bx is the
set
that
describes all the possible
determinations of each sample x
and we will design the consistency
regularization which will help us to do
the
label propagation algorithm
and this consistency regularization just
measures the amount
of inconsistent set of any given
classified g
which means like it's the probability of
each of x such that there exists an
augmented data
where their predictions are different
and in this figure it will be just be
the probability of this
dashed part
but because there exists like a
label of sorry determination or like
just a small deviation on each sample
but their predictions are different
and with this kind of consistency
regularization we can
present our label propagation algorithm
so as i said the main idea is to
minimize the difference to the teacher
classifying the source domain while
ensuring the augmented data to predict
similarly among all unlabeled samples
so our idea is like
is like this so we'll minimize
the difference of our prediction of our
learned classified with the teacher
classified
and meanwhile we will minimize we will
ensure that the consistency
regularization
to be small
and this mu
is a hyper parameter we want to tune
so let's suppose we have a ground shoes
classifier that performs consistent
among all
data sets for example in this case if
there is a consistent
uh if there is a good quantity
classified that is consistent among all
label
all augmented samples then this mu
should be zero
but as otherwise we will need this mu to
be larger than the
value that is given by the ground choose
classifier
and our final result of the test
performance will depend on this mu
okay then we will give the theoretical
analysis
so first
is the ideal case let's say there exists
a realizable
robust classifier which means there
exists such a good classifier
such that it can
separate all the
samples
but in the meantime there's no
consistent
set which means there's no point that
when you add labor force uh we'll add a
data mutation
or like add some small deviations where
the predictions remains the same
then in this case or just proof by
picture you can see the main idea of our
label propagation algorithm is to first
realize on each like component from the
source domain this value is
the majority
of the prediction value is
one
and
since you want to
maintain that there's no inconsistent
set
which means which connected component we
should predict the same value so in this
component it will predict our one value
and similarly
with this this component will predict -1
etc
then our algorithm will learn a perfect
classifier if the teacher classifier is
at least 51
correct on each component of the source
data
and beyond the perfect case let's relax
the assumption
if there exists a mis-specification
which means the ground choose classify
the inconsistence that
has the probability of mu
then
this means that
it's possible that data augmentation
might connect to different classes by
mistake
for example you have like random crop on
the belly of a cat and value of a dog
and they look similar it's possible that
they are connected in the representation
space
but that
that will happen very well so mu would
be a small value and we can still handle
that point and my the main idea is like
still similarly we will take like the
majority value of the source domain and
propagate that to the
unambiguous region where for the
ambiguous region we will do something
like majority voting
and to use this idea we need a technical
assumption which is the data mutation
should have this
expensive property
this is proposed by way at all 2021
uh and it is saying that data mutation
can enlarge any small enough set to say
times larger
and they have verified this kind of
assumption by empirical
validation
and more formally it's saying like we're
seeing each connected component for any
small enough set a by small enough i
mean that the probability of this set
is less or equal to this a
or then when you do data momentation of
the entire set its probability is
enlarged by c times
so this is sort of thing like the
strings of determination how much more
samples can create with the current
samples
and we can show that if the data
satisfies a half c
expensiveness the determination satisfy
that
then the target error
of the learned classified given by our
label propagation algorithm
is upper bounded by order mu over c
where remember mu is the
inconsistency probability of the
bronchus classified
and if we believe mu is very small then
this value is also very small since c is
always larger than zero
and of course this value is given by
like training on the probability of
population
risk but the results naturally extend to
finite example result with some standard
analysis
so this is like the approximation error
well we'll add some estimation error
with some concentration on the
um your network or as a or other
function can be used
before moving on to the experimental
result i will also i want to emphasize
this idea actually applies generally so
previously i'm talking about a source
domain and the target domain that we
have unlabeled samples from those and
this is
the setting of unsupervised domain
adaptation
however the idea of label progression
applies more generally because
as long as the connected components of
the unlabeled samples we have covers
both the source and target domain that
we can perform the propagation in
general
so
it also applies to like semi-supervised
learning which means like the unlabeled
samples we have from the same
distribution as the source and target
domain because you see even if the
teacher network you originally have only
performs like 51 accuracy you can
actually
correct the
the teacher network and have better
performance even in the original uh
source domain
and
it also applies to other settings for
example if we have multiple
domains
the
multiple source domains
that is like domain generalization
yeah
oh
then let's look at the experimental
evaluation we look at we are looking at
two types of data set
one is um a
benchmark data set for domain adaptation
tasks for example with office home data
set it has four different domains like
art leave heart
to real world and it has different
classes
and
we also have office 31 data set and we
evaluate our method and compare
compared it with some other
state-of-the-art method
called mdd margin disparity discrepancy
and we realize that by adapting
from
the source domain to different target
domain the performance of of our
algorithm is better than the
previous algorithm
and another type of data set
we use is enter entity 31
from rates
and it has different uh
data set where it has some population
shift meaning that
for each
for each class
so it has data sampled from different
subclasses
and on this data set we showed
that
our method has much better performance
than the previous different methods
just focus on the test accuracy here
okay
um
so
our analysis is actually based on
propagating fact labels to images closed
in semantic
meanings
and that is measured by the closeness of
two images in the representation space
and
i haven't talked about how to achieve
such a useful presentation space yet so
now let's talk about that
the representation space we get is
through self-supervised learning
and specifically
one type of self-supervised algorithms
that's called similarity-based
self-supervised learning because the
main idea is to enforcing to enforce two
views of the same data to have similar
representations
like
if we randomly sample each uh sample
some image and we take uh random
determination different random
determinations
these are just two views of the same
data so we should expect their
representation
to be similar
and there are different algorithms that
learn the representation with this kind
of idea
and the difference is they define they
design different loss functions to
maximize the agreement
among those representations
and
they use different methods to avoid
collapse
because you see one trivial way to
enforce set the representation of this
x1 and x2 to be the same is to predict
all one function a trivial function but
that's not something you want it
has
hasn't captured the like meaning of
different images
and they use different ways to avoid
collapse
and this algorithm
is actually
the same spirit as the
conventional canonical correlation
analysis
but because if you recall what is the
cca or non-linear cca it is trying to
maximize the inner product between the
representation plus psi x1
inner product with
the another representation on x2
with the samples from their drawing
distribution and
also to to make sure that the
representation function is normalized
so you can see it is
very similar to the other
self-supervised learning algorithm we
want to
make sure that their agreement is
maximized
the representation of their of this x1
and x2 their agreement is maximized
well the difference is they use
different ways to prevent collapse like
cca uses kind of
normalization
well seems cyan is another net
another method it use batch norm and
stop gradient to avoid collapse and
contrastive learning it uses negative
samples to avoid collapse
but with cca it has a clean cleaner
statistical meanings and we are able to
analyze that
and with the nonlinear cca algorithm
we can actu actually show such a very
clean result
suppose that
with x1 we are able to predict
the label y with high accuracy or like
the base error of the ground choose
classifier to predict y given x1 is very
small
then we can actually show that the
approximation error of using a linear
function on the learned representation
to predict y
from the learned representation plus x1
is upper bounded by mu divided one minus
lambda k and the lambda case the case
maximum correlation
between x1 and x2 it just measures some
dependence between x1 and x two and it's
guaranteed to be smaller than one as
long as x two and the x one are not
exactly the same
so this means
that as long as we believe
that x with x
one
the
uh the label is almost deterministic
then
um the label
y actually can be linearly separable
by this learned representation plus x1
yeah so this shows that the learned
representation almost linearly separates
in label y and this means the l2
distance in the representation space
will indicate whether two images are
more likely to belong to the same class
and that explains why label propagation
in such representation space is much
better than propagating on the original
input space
oh and in conclusion
we have analyzed that
consistency regularization under data
augmentation
not only will correct misclassified
samples in semi-surprise learning
but also can propagate the crack labels
to other domains with some label samples
and in the meantime self-suffice
learning is the proper metric that will
aid this procedure
and that's the end of this talk thank
you
any questions
well thank you g
any questions for chi
so let me start with one uh could you
tell more about the training procedure
like um
you wrote in the middle of the joker
constraint optimization problem and uh
yeah i was wondering how you do that in
practice
uh yes
uh that's a good point uh
so the the actual the actual algorithm
we use or actual method we use a
there's a
discrepancy
from the theoretical algorithm
theoretical the analyzed algorithm
so we are actually applying a
existing
loss function with
fixed match
to our representation space
so but the difference is like fixed
match was designed for semi-supervised
learning and we
just use their design consistency
regularization to our problem and
extend it to this domain adaptation
problem with unlabeled samples from the
target domain and we also like apply it
to the representation space
there's a difference
yeah but the actual
actual loss function we use are not
exactly like this
yeah sorry
and that's exactly like this oh this is
this you cannot estimate efficiently
so the actually consistency
regularization is like uh
we sample the
we have the sample the batch of samples
and
minimize
the difference between
this prediction and the
augmented samples prediction
thank you i think grant uh oh shafi has
a question
in the beginning you said that uh
in the beginning you said that the whole
approach is to solicit more data
right uh in order to be able to handle
the
distributional shift so and maybe i
missed it but is where is the where does
that come about how much more data
that was in the beginning at the
beginning you know the first those
slides or something i think you said
that
uh yeah so uh
you mean this like we need additional
data right yeah so what is the
quantity
so so the in the traditional supervised
learning setting we only have
labeled samples from the source domain
here we assume we have additional
unlabeled samples from the target domain
i'm asking how much yeah
how much um
you mean like in theory or in practice
uh in theory well in syria well our
analysis actually assume we have like uh
free access to the unlabeled samples
so you cannot
if you have any examples in the training
is sufficient to have n examples in the
[Music]
in the
testing afterwards or do you need more
than that possible
oh sorry i didn't hear there could be
more than the amount of training with
the blitz label or the same amount
oh yeah in the in our analysis the
unlabeled samples are much more than the
label samples because they are almost
free to get their own label samples
yeah we didn't actually analyze the
sample complexity for unlabeled samples
so
just to continue the question uh
how would they could you use them
yeah sure
just continue the question how does
the
unlabeled data
appear
as a performance to the rate
in comparison with the
lower
oh
you mean like how
does the amount of unlabeled samples
appear in the result
right yeah somehow it should appear
right yeah
our analysis actually
suppose we have like the free access to
all the unlikable samples
so it doesn't appear so it's it's only a
statistical result so not about like
tractability or like optimization
efficiency
so it's saying that we only
analyze the sample capacity for
uh
for label samples we didn't analyze
sample competitive for unlabeled samples
so it doesn't appear
follow up on the same thread like is it
possible that you generate this data
yourself
these additional samples that's what i
understand
to generate the data
i don't know can you generate some fake
samples that kind of look like they
could be from that distribution or maybe
it doesn't make sense in your setting
anymore
um
i think that's that's very good idea and
many people are doing that
uh like you can
like change the background
you split the data
with a foreground background and change
the background that's how
people are creating different uh
different domains
um
artificially
yeah that's uh that would be a good idea
but not necessarily related to our
setting for now
i think grant had a question
that quickly flashed uh of the
his grant there
maybe the grant kind of mute himself and
asked the question
i think the question was along the lines
of what are your next steps in this line
of work
oh i see yeah so so as you guys have
mentioned uh there's a very good point
that it's it's worthwhile also to
analyze the sample complexity for on
label samples that's one thing and also
here i only analyze the covariate for
classification task
but
because you see like with classification
tests the label i just is discrete there
are two values always a regression it
might be harder
but still possible that could be a next
step and also other types of
distribution shift like model shift
thanks
yeah
thank you
so i guess uh i was wondering like uh
i guess i'm probably missing some
details but like
in principle you could imagine that in
many applications
you can continuously move in the space
of uh
inputs or possible inputs to go from
like any pair of animals to like any
animal to any other like you know you
have birds on the trees and then you
know squirrels on the trees and then
decent like
like what like
i wonder like do you do you want to be
in a situation where kind of like
most of your connected components are
pretty clearly
a certain label uh
like if you're in a situation where kind
of like all clusters
you know are consistent with two labels
uh yeah
um or not no but like every cluster at
some point gets one label and at some
point other point gets another label
like is that it like is that breaking
down your framework here or
um
yeah so
oh
yeah actually
like a preconditional thing of your
theorem at least was
that this doesn't happen very often this
disagrees
exactly so i think we should like
balance these two so you if you have
like super strong
determination that can connect any
class to another class i would say
that's a data augmentation
the meaning for determination is that
you shouldn't change its original
semantic meanings
yeah i guess what i'm afraid is like
rather than cropping the feathers of the
bird you instead crop the trunk of the
tree
and then you know in a different picture
the same trunk of a tree has a squirrel
on it and then
you know all birds and all squirrels and
this stuff like that may happen so but
yeah i see your point so
yeah must be some uh augmentation that
doesn't kind of connect the whole space
yeah yeah so we also handle that but so
you should make sure that this
probability of connecting two classes to
be small
otherwise there's no like branches
classified either
so
i mean won't choose robust classifier
all right so
is there no further question let's uh uh
thank g again
thank you
glad to see you all